think about it while you know in
financial services or different
verticals data is what drives the
business here in these critical
infrastructure organizations the
production lines are driving the
business these OT operational technology
assets are driving the business the iot
assets these physical assets the
controller in a manufacturing floor
production line a PLC or in a fusion
palom in a hospital
these devices are really driving the
business serving our lives right if it's
a water utility or electric utility or a
hospital the way we uh we get these
Services is through these physical
assets so that's the hardcore of the
businesses and not protecting the
hardcore of these businesses and just
focusing on the data centers servers
laptops what have you the manag
devices that obviously creat it's a
bigger
risk Yaniv vardy welcome to 20-minute
leaders I'm so happy to have you with me
how are you excellent thank you so much
for having me Michael phenomenal to have
you here Yan today you're the CEO of I
think one of the most interesting cyber
companies probably in the world
Clarity because you're dealing with the
cyber security in the contexts that are
not trivial they're both both in the
terms of the complexity and how
important they are effectively in
critical infrastructure H but also just
Thea the the path of clarity I think has
been fascinating and one that's very
very much in line with the startup
nation and and what we embody a little
bit before we get into your work today
tell me a little bit about yourself your
the way you came into cyber security how
do you end up leading this company yes
of course sure um so um you know before
Clarity um I spent about 10 years in the
US in New York graduated from industrial
engineering there and started my journey
one of the companies there spart
systems um ending up um leading the uh
um the company um um also here from uh
from from Israel uh for um for about
eight years selling the company and
later on uh managing panoramic power
which was focusing on Energy Efficiency
and operational efficiency um which I
sold to centrica British gas um and
managing the international business for
that company um I was approached by the
board and um I thought very highly of
the opportunity one because you know
it's um it's a great mission statement
that we have protecting cyber physical
systems in critical infrastructure
organization ations and two I was very
intrigued by the um by the opportunity
to really understand the
challenges of protecting these
industrial manufacturing and healthc
care
companies um and understand how to go
about that I think very highly of the
opportunity because we protect people's
lives if you think about that we're not
protecting just data or you know
personal information or credit card
information we protect people's lives
there day in and day out if it's a
hospital if it's an industrial or
Manufacturing Company um people lives
are at risk there um and you know we're
very much proud with the mission
statement that we are pushing forward
and this is what was for me very very
attractive to take it one from a
business perspective and build a
business here um that uh that is a
market leader and two with a mission
statement that is truly critical and
important in today's world I love it so
let's take a step back for a second and
you know cyber security comes in all
shapes and sizes and I think the
majority of of categories in the cyber
security space are leaning much more
towards the digitized space you know
that we we went from the the networking
firewalls in the 95 to to the semantics
and malware detection for operating
systems to cloud and identity and zero
trust and and and we see what's
happening with AI today where does this
physical security fit in here and you
know how you know place this for me in
the cyber security context sure I'll
take a step back actually think about
the world today digital transformation
is really pushing industrial
manufacturing health care companies to
connect connect all their physical
assets to improve their business to be
more productive to be more efficient to
more competitive so if you think about
industrial companies manufacturing
companies Healthcare um the race to
connectivity to get all these benefits
is clear but by far outpa the ability to
secure it you know I compared that um to
years ago where the internet was coming
up the the need for the internet and the
value and benefits for the internet was
great but obviously at the beginning not
secure
that's what we see today today there are
more unmanaged connected physical assets
than number of people and it's growing
significantly think about it Michael we
think that in the next few years we'll
exceed 30 billion devices physical
assets that are connected for these
companies to obviously be more
productive but not secured and that
creating a bigger risk that expending
the a attx surface that's basically
really putting these companies and
people at risk where we are not secured
mostly um and with these critical
assets and what's at stake so 30 billion
so the the race to connectivity yes the
upsides of course the what what is that
stake here if these devices this this
connectivity maintains unmanaged and
unsecured what what what what could we
be facing or what have we experienced
that could help us understand why this
is a mission critical area sure so think
about it while you know in financial
services or different verticals data is
what drives the business here in these
critical infrastructure organizations
the production lines are driving the
business these OT operational technology
assets are driving the business the iot
assets these physical assets the
controller in a manufacturing floor
production line a PLC or in a fusion
pump in a hospital these devices are
really driving the business serving our
lives right if it's a water utility or
electric utility or a hospital the way
we uh we get these Services is through
these physical assets so that's the
hardcore of the businesses and not
protecting the hardcore of these
businesses and just focusing on the data
centers servers laptops what have you
the managed
devices that obviously creates a bigger
risk and hence the uh unfortunately the
number of attacks that we see today that
is increasing and the risk if an
attacker is getting to an HMI and a
PLC um that is changing the chemical mix
um through a water pump or a controller
that can kill people if an attacker is
getting to a production line of a car
manufacturer and now manage the robots
there that can create a huge risk when
you see Vol typhoon the Chinese uh
government and the program that were
that they deployed on critical
infrastructure in the US that's creating
you know a risk to people's lives when
networks in
hospitals are are down because of a
ransomware attack and the hospital is
not functioning anymore and patients are
moving from One hospital to another
because of that that's killing people if
a sensor in a hospital is not
functioning anymore because of an attack
that can cause a risk to live so we're
talking about critical infrastructure
organizations that they're hardcore of
these organizations are these physical
assets that let them you know provide
the services and push forward to
basically have us you know benefit from
these services so they can sustain our
lives so it it sounds like there's a
huge fragmentation of systems that are
vulnerable to these attacks right so and
and I'm curious if you can help me
understand the stack so there's always
you know the the I guess the the
electricity running and then there's the
operating system and and networking how
maybe can can you walk me through the
stack for these physical devices and
where Clarity fits in in terms of its
security alongside this Tex teac sure so
think about you know the industrial
manufacturing there's the Purdue model
with different layers but the way to
look at that Michael is first the um the
need for visibility and I'm using the
Gardner
uh customer journey to kind of describe
to you where we sit in the stack but
also how the customer is looking at the
journey so first is visibility we have
the ability to really orchestrate the
different ways of getting the data to
map the entire network for our customers
if it's active or passive configuration
files Integrations we collect the data
map the network for our customers and be
able to show the uh full visibility of
all physical assets and all connected
devices um in the network and then we
start to provide exposure management to
our customers identifying the risk and
vulnerabilities but also helping these
customers to prioritize the
vulnerabilities on these critical assets
where the asset purpose is key to
understand as part of the critical
process that we are focusing on so
prioritizing the risk and the
vulnerability
and then provide Network protection to
our customers through Network policies
for example taking actions as far as
zones and segmentations the ability to
really reduce the risk with actions and
not just showing the risk and the
vulnerabilities for for our customers we
provide thread detection continuous
thread detection obviously connecting
with the sock and making sure that we
are embedded within their
ecosystem that they have and making sure
they have the data from us in real time
as well as securing the remote access
into these assets as part of our
platform and I think today as opposed to
few years ago the value of having one
comprehensive platform the holistic
approach is critical because customers
have enough Solutions out there to
integrate and service and all that and
so like I said securing the remote
access into the network and not just
identifying these assets but securing
the remote access into these Assets in
the network in a very secure way with
Pam and ztna capabilities is critical
especially today with a third party risk
that everyone is talking
about I I'd love to double click with
you on this context of risk assessment
on the attack surface because I think
that's one of the things that I would
imagine and you and you mentioned that
the values they providing here is the
ability to look at the to look at the
landscape and and come to the Security
Professionals and say here is where we
believe you may be vulnerable and here
is what could happen if we don't take
action and um and and I think especially
as you look at these different devices
that are doing different actions it's
because also because of their fragmented
nature and what they're aspiring to do
it's not as trivial as another database
in the cloud another laptop another
another router or switch what have you
found successful in being able to
articulate the risk assessments or the
risk levels to Security Professionals
that help them be most effective in
communicating it so that they understand
it and then take action yeah that's a
good question Michael I think first of
all it's fair to say that these guys
look at a traditional ways of securing
their networks and thinking it's just
not effective anymore so to that point
point the ability to identify the risk
and the vulnerabilities on specific
assets is not enough because you can
have thousands of
vulnerabilities on your assets and in
iot you can have hundreds of thousands
of
vulnerabilities and 22% last year for
example of this huge number were
critical so if you're a customer if
you're a sis and I'm telling you you
have thousands of vulnerabilities and by
the way it's all critical what do you do
with that you cannot go and Patch
especially not in production lines
manufacturing or hospitals you cannot
just go and Patch these thousands of uh
of assets with these critical
vulnerabilities but we are focusing on
these critical processes we understand
the asset purpose the actual asset
purpose Within These critical processes
we see what vulnerabilities were
exploited we are able to prioritize
these vulnerabilities and the risk risk
and show you the risk hygiene and the
factors that can actually help you to
reduce the risk and the actions with
zones and segmentations for example that
can help you to reduce the risk the
significant risk reduction with specific
actions and not just bombarding you with
all the vulnerabilities and the risk and
everything that everyone is doing
because it's just like I said not
effective anymore but being very focused
on what actions needs to be done what
are the network policies that should be
enforced and how to do that and I think
that's very unique to Clarity to
leverage our domain expertise with the
asset Purpose with the critical
processes with the critical and
exploited vulnerabilities and the
network policies combine that with
threat detection and remote access
security that these are the domain
expertise that are bringing us to the
table and usually why you know customers
are choosing Clarity over the others so
how important really is domain expertise
in in this context uh you see a lot of a
cyber companies with great technologists
many of them are generalists that are
able to create good technology for
detection or assessments or reporting
Etc um it feels like Clarity is
operating in a domain that does have you
know the that you can leverage domain
expertise how but but how how really do
you feel it is important here from your
customers perspectives that your domain
experts and and what is the domain
expertise really on sure so the domain
expertise are on the actual assets their
protocols communication what a good
communication looks like between these
assets what are these specific
proprietary protocols that are Simmons
or Schneider Rockwell protocols that we
need to actually identify to be able and
identify the assets I'll take take a
step back without these domain expertise
Michael first it's hard to identify
these assets and how can you manage or
protect what you don't see and so first
is really identifying these assets and
you need this domain expertise to
understand and have these proprietary
protocols to understand these assets and
the asset purpose and so on second like
I said the traditional way of doing
vulnerability management and risk
management is just not valid anymore
especially with physical Assets in these
critical infrastructure organizations
and so if you don't have this domain
expertise you have hard time to
prioritize these actions and these
Network policies for these customers and
you end up being a very generic
solution that every cyber company can
come try to do everything to everyone
that's not working for these
manufacturing folks or the industrial
folks or hospitals in healthcare they
understand the need for domain expertise
and they will try to avoid these generic
Solutions out there what do you have
most fun in in your journey so far what
what's been the most exhilarating part
of of running Clarity wow that's uh
that's a good question look I get my
energy from uh meting customers
customers and partners to be honest I uh
I just came from uh I don't think I can
um you know share the the name of the
customer but one of the biggest
Industrial company in the US just
understand what's the value they get
from Clarity and how they improve their
business and operational efficiency not
just is cyber and and the way we protect
but operational efficiency I get my
energy from from these customer meetings
to be honest um customer and partners
and that's for me that's great that's
fun um I also to be honest enjoy the
team we have a great team and we like to
um you know work hard play hard and uh
at the end of the day I also enjoyed the
team so you know time that we spent with
the team just came back from New York we
spent a few days before the board
meeting um with the team together kind
of uh you know finalizing the plans for
next year you know we enjoyed that I
love it you I really want to thank you
for taking the time to to join me here H
this was such an awesome conversation I
I learned a lot on the personal level
and uh thank you for all the amazing
work you're doing obviously it's it's
not just about for you not just about
making money and building a successful
company but the impact that you're
having both on the the the the impact
specifically on the cesos that are
experiencing the product but then even
more broadly I think the the first
sentence you said in this episode is
that you know you really feel like
you're you're saving people's lives
which I think is a it's obviously a
great motivator H Yan thank you so much
and uh best of luck thank you so much
Michael take care